hey guys today's video will be a little
bit different than usually I won't be
talking about one piece but I'd rather
like to talk a little bit about channel
related things so I recently came back
from short trip to Japan I did to visit
some old friends and to get back into
the city I lived in and while I was
diving into all the Japanese habits you
do when you go to Tokyo like eating
ramen whatever call it call it what you
want call it cliches I did all of it and
while I was enjoying my time there I
figured it's about time that I properly
introduced myself to you guys and as
some of you guys might have noticed I
recently yeah
maybe probably one or two weeks ago hit
the 100 mark now I know I'm a little bit
late in addressing this and I'm really
sorry for that because I think the
subscriber count has gone up to 140
roughly which is just incredible but I
definitely want you guys to know that it
definitely means like a great great deal
to me reaching 100 subscribers on
YouTube and that actually in a pretty
fast period of time like I didn't expect
it to go that fast I'm incredibly
thankful that you guys support me it
means a lot to me I can only do what I
do because of your support your comments
are just amazing I love engaging with
you I I love that you love the content I
make and help me prove it that's even
more important to me thank you so much
for being there thank you for enjoying
one piece with me that's just amazing an
amazing opportunity for me to share my
passion in such a way with so many
people who who love it just as well as I
do now at this point I want to make a
shout out and some of you might already
have a person in mind big big thank you
and big shout-out to mr. March who many
of you guys probably came from to me
he's a great guy I love his videos
I know you guys do if you don't know him
and actually haven't checked out his
videos definitely check him out I'll put
a link to his channel in the description
below and he makes amazing analytical
videos of bumpy's great reviews make
sure to check him out
and since we're collaborating a little
bit on smaller things I'm sure you will
see more of him and maybe also hopefully
of me in the future together so now at
this point I would like to introduce
myself a little bit to every one of you
who's rather new to the channel who only
maybe has seen one or two videos of me
and basically my idea is
what I like to do one on YouTube here is
to take topics from one piece that
haven't been looked at properly or
concepts that I find in the anime or
already manga that I find interesting
that are maybe LLL not ask obvious and
try to analyze them try to explain them
I don't think I make things very
differently from most other wimpy
youtubers I like to analyze the manga I
like to explain concepts to you guys I
like to discover new things I like to do
theories and maybe later on if there
ever should be interest from you guys I
will definitely consider after getting
warmed up a little bit here on YouTube
to also start making chapter reviews
because I'm really looking forward to
that I'm just still having a little bit
respect I'm doing it so uh yeah
if you guys would like to see me doing
that definitely let me know but it'll
probably be like a few more month to
just like get going like get to use get
used to all the YouTube stuff here get
used to talking and stuff like that it's
pretty new to me really exciting but I
definitely want to do that it's
definitely my bucket list and now guys
last but not least I would like to
celebrate the 100 subscribers with you
guys your support and you keep this
channel going so I want to say thank you
by making a video you guys want me to
make so I will my idea basically was
that the comment under this video
that gets the most likes will be the
topic that I will make my next video
about preferably I'll try to actually
make it on the weekend if I won't be
able to do it on the weekend before
Christmas due to the usual Christmas
dress I'll definitely get it out the
week after and I think you can look
forward to some nice stuff over the
holidays too so definitely think of a
cool topic you want me to talk about and
put it in the comments below and maybe
also share why you think that's a good
topic to talk about I'm really curious
if that will work out I hope you guys
participate I'm really looking forward
to that and also want you guys to
actively shape the channel with me now I
think I've been bubbling on for long
enough thank you so much for your
support again I really appreciate what
you guys do I really appreciate you
enjoying my content
and I hope that we will be together on
this journey for a long long time
take care and I hope to see you in the
next video
you